death stranding once exclusive to the
ps4 is now on pc
with the proper specs this game can look
and run so much better than it did on
ps4
and it even has some neat half-life and
portal crossover content to boot
that's all to say that if you miss death
stranding the first time around
now's the time to become an expert
porter like it or not it's a bold game
and in the year of our lord 2020 it's
quite uh
timely with its theme of being an
essential worker during a catastrophic
event
that leads to a nationwide quarantine
for those living under a rock and not to
avoid time fall
here's the short of it death stranding
is metal gear creator hideo kojima's
latest
your delivery man played by actor norman
reedus amid a deadly paranormal
phenomenon called the death stranding
that forces the surviving population to
seek refuge in underground bunkers
while the game has a fair share of third
person stealth action
it's also quite literally a walking or
hiking simulator
where balancing your cargo and
traversing harsh terrain are core
gameplay elements
it's all wrapped around a heavily
cinematic and somewhat bizarre story
about human connection
self-serious but engrossing at the same
time its broader message is made
manifest in its asynchronous multiplayer
in which the actions of others
such as laying down ladders bridges and
roads will affect your own game world
everyone's just helping each other make
their deliveries stay alive on a hostile
surface
and chug their oddly place monster
energy drinks to keep on keeping on
even though you never see your fellow
players giving them a few likes for
their work
and getting a few in return is sort of
uplifting we recognized it as one of the
best of 2019
and my friend and colleague callie
plegue spoke to its qualities in her
full review from last year
now i'm here to report that it remains a
superb game
and it has been enhanced by pc exclusive
features
that'll draw you into its vast beautiful
and desolate world
the enhanced experience is of course
subject to your own pc specs
and performance may vary i ran a
high-end build using an intel core i7
7700k
16 gigabytes of ram a samsung 970 pro
nvme ssd
and the nvidia rtx 2080 video card i had
every setting maxed out
and ran a resolution of 2560 by 1080
which is 21x9 ultra wide
and with nvidia's rtx exclusive dlss 2.0
anti-aliasing enabled
here's a quick look at your options dlss
in particular is a tremendous option for
those running higher resolutions like 4k
it's nvidia's ai based super sampling
tech that provides native res image
quality while rendering a slightly lower
resolution underneath
boosting your fps output however you
will need an rtx video card to use this
feature it's worth noting that
anisotropic filtering is not a native
option in the menu
and you'll have to manually force it
through the nvidia control panel or amd
equivalent
this is important because death
stranding features long stretches of
land
and anisotropic filtering does a lot of
work in cleaning up the image quality
of surfaces in the distance throughout
my time with the game
i was able to maintain 90 to 110 fps
out in the open world and in heated
moments of intense action
regardless of how heavy the weather
effects got cutscenes are kept to 60 fps
but that's largely a non-issue
while i'm not able to test out 4k
metrics due to circumstances
others such as digital foundry are
reporting great performance and visuals
with 4k and dlss as well as solid
results from modest machines with the
proper settings
i wouldn't say frame rate is critical to
your success or the overall enjoyment
but it certainly bolsters the death
stranding experience gameplay ran like a
dream with silky smooth performance
which made action sequences more
manageable and the treks across
vast planes more pleasing since i'm
running an nvme ssd
the game initially loads in a matter of
a few seconds and even quicker in every
other instance
again if you have the right hardware
it's a drastic improvement over the ps4
version
death stranding also features native
controller support but if you're
inclined to use keyboard and mouse
the control scheme translates sensibly
the only issue is that death stranding
has a big focus on movement
and whether on foot or in a vehicle wasd
might not be your best bet
as for the pc exclusive valve crossover
content it should put a smile on the
faces of half-life and portal fans
it consists of six short side quests
sprinkled throughout the game
these are given through emails marked
with the lambda and each
instance asks you to track down a
companion cube that's out in the world
the story behind these tasks take a
mysterious tone breaking the fourth wall
but we won't spoil what happens here now
the gear that you get out of the quests
can be quite useful while gordon's
glasses and the valve headpiece are
purely cosmetic
the gravity glove lets you pick up cargo
from a distance
the headcrab hat can use sam's blood to
replenish stamina
and the half-life truck better
withstands deterioration
i know playing courier with the
occasional action sequence may not sound
enticing
but if you have the time and patience
there's nothing quite like it
death stranding can be quite an intense
experience encountering the terrifying
ghostly bts who often occupy hostile
zones
unroute to your objective or crossing
paths with rogue mule bandits
but most other times death training is
incredibly therapeutic you have a lot of
time to reflect on your actions and the
story beats
while soaking in the beautiful vistas
and mountain ranges
on your way to finish delivery orders as
a soothing low roar song plays
with death stranding being a largely
visually captivating experience
this is where the pc version shines
specifically
enhanced visuals and much higher frame
rates further elevate those awe
inspiring moments
by no means was the ps4 version a slouch
when it came to impressive visuals
the cut scenes starring finely detailed
character models
and environments are a testament to that
but through this magnificent port here
on pc
the world you explore in death stranding
can be all the more striking
[Music]